okay so I can't play piano very fast so
this is an update from what the song I
made yesterday imagine it's like I hit
every note and it's just amazing see the
vision okay we don't party like we used
to take me back to
1992 everybody's acting brand new we're
not looking across the room
everybody is looking down on their
phones no one's
around yeah we used to tear up the town
now I don't hear a sound
cuz people don't dance cuz Somebody's
Watching drink too much everybody's
talking we used to rage like there was
no stopping so put your hands up
everybody's
rocking put your phone down and get on
the dance floor shake that booty like
you never did before look real silly and
raise your hands let's get together and
baby just
dance photo shoot at the back door
taking pictures of the Town horse
there's more to life than what we got in
store and maybe I'm just a little bored
edited pictures on
Instagram last night she's decked out in
Glam maybe I just don't give a damn I
won't live for Instagram
cuz people don't dance cuz Somebody's
Watching drink too much everybody's
talking we used to rage like there was
no stopping so put your hands up
everybody's
rocking put your phone down and get on
the dance floor shake that booty like
you never did before look real silly and
raise your hands let's get together and
baby Just
Dance take a picture so they know you're
there even though nobody cares we used
to play truth or dare get too drunk
without a care everybody's checking
their phones I ain't surprised we feel
so alone knock knock knock nobody's home
the world we used to know is gone
so cuz people don't dance cuz Somebody's
Watching drink too much everybody's
talking we used to rage like like there
was no stopping so put your hands up
everybody's rocking put your phone down
and get on the dance floor shake that
booty like you never did before look
real silly and raise your hands let's
get together and baby Just
Dance take a shot and get your move on
oh be like Stella and get your groove
on
cuz people don't dance cuz Somebody's
Watching drink too much everybody's
talking we used to rage like there was
no stopping so put your hands up
everybody's rocking put your phone down
and get on the dance floor shake that
booty like you never ever did before
look real silly and raise your hands
let's get together and baby Just
[Music]
Dance So I need to make it a little
shorter on the lyrics I think I have too
many but that's the
rough how it's
going if you guys have any like edits or
notes put it in the comments and we
could sort of you know write this
together yes